[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this is the
channel where we explain it so you don't
have to Game of Thrones is back and
those who've been eagerly awaiting a new
season from the show like I have are in
for a real treat
episode one has just dropped on HBO and
there's a lot to unpack from its story
and ending throughout this video I'll be
breaking down everything that you need
to know about episode 1 as well as what
it could lead to down the line this is
full spoilers ahead so if you haven't
seen the premiere yeah and don't want to
know what happens then I highly
recommend that you save this video till
after you've watched episode 1 as there
are some great moments without the way I
hope you enjoyed the video now sit back
relax and let's get into my ending
explain breakdown of Game of Thrones
season 8 episode 1 along with a complete
overhaul to the opening the season 8
premiere was very much like a high
school reunion
this episode felt like a big catch up
after all the things that have happened
over the past 7 seasons and it worked
great for setting up plot points going
forward this was very much a callback to
the first ever episode in which the
families descended upon Winterfell and
we watched as Daenerys met with everyone
before sending her army to fight the
undead everyone is here Tyron Ian sees
Sansa John sees area and the to even
compare swords and it's just a great
family catcher my favorite one in the
episode was probably when the Hound met
with area and I loved being reminded of
how much of a badass she is this isn't
really the time to ask for everyone's
status update though and the Lord of the
North's are struggling to deal with the
fact that John Benton II whilst John
seems to be the only one who realizes
how important the union between the two
is with his new aunty I mean girlfriend
everyone else is a bit set against it
this is obviously setting up things down
the line and you get the feeling that
fighting the undead isn't going to be
easy when all of the factions are
warring with one another
meanwhile at King's Landing Cersei is
delighted that the dead have broken
through the wall and
to Winterfell what a [ __ ] anyway now
she's got so much free time on her hands
Circe meets with Greyjoy who presents
captain Strickland the new leader of the
golden company he's basically the guy
you swipe right on tinder with when
you're trying to get over Jaime
Lannister and you remember that he's
your brother anyway it turns out that
the golden company were catfishing
Cersei a bit and they don't have the
numbers that they promised I wanted
those elephants to Cersei I want my
elephant wrapped with Angus Cersei puts
a bounty on both her brother's heads and
wants them killed with the crossbow that
was used to murder her father bit of a
Chekhov's gun coming in there which is
quite nice and I hope that's a bit of
irony in that whole situation we also
get to see the magic carpet ride that
opens up a whole new world for John and
Danny back at Winterfell we see the two
riding atop of them in probably one of
the most anticipated scenes of the
entire run so far they flied to
waterfall and make out which is a bit of
a gut punch especially with what comes
after here Sam finds out through Dany
that his father and brother are dead and
then it was through dragon fire that
they died because they wouldn't bend the
knee now this point bran informs him
that it's time to fill John in on who he
really is and he starts upping the ante
by telling John that he's been well up
in his ante
John's obviously not happy and I can see
this sort of playing into the future
when the two have to decide who should
be sat on the throne we also get the
reveal that Tolman didn't die in the
wall melt and whilst this was spoiled in
some of season eights trailers it's nice
to see him alive and kicking the
remaining members of the Night Watch he
found and they revealed that the night
King has left his lovely calling card
which is a child stuck to the wall
surrounded by limbs you could have just
left Knight King was the heir Season
seven but never mind anyway in the
closing moments of the show a dark
mysterious rider arrives at Winterfell
and we see that it's Jaime Lannister
bran watches him probably aware of the
significance of his arrival and still
angry that he's the reason he's in a
wheelchair
now whether bran will won revenge is a
different matter but a further showcases
their unease in the camps this sums up
the episode as a whole whilst the forces
are having to work together to fight the
undead we get the feeling that they
don't really want to be deep down this
is cemented by Jon who everyone thinks
is wrong for Ben
the down the line this will probably
stop him getting his throne as people
will not trust his leadership but I
guess we will find out as the season
goes on
I just hope him and Sam get to become
best mates again because damn that's
friendship Gold's right there anyway
what did you think of the episode and
did it live up to the hype for you
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and make sure you check out my breakdown
of the final episode of The Walking Dead
which will be linked at the end I'm
going to be breaking down every episode
of Game of Thrones week by week so make
sure you stay locked into the channel
for updates every Monday this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]